[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 148
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Randall, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick, yet again
after a short hiatus.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
Welcome back.
MARK MANDEL: Welcome
back to you, too.
I think we've both been
traveling a whole lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, we were.
And I know last week you were
a little tied up over in Tokyo.
Where were you in Tokyo?
What were you up to?
MARK MANDEL: So, yeah.
I was over in Tokyo.
I was at Cloud Next presenting
at the inside version of Cloud
Next, so the game conference
that was like a little side
thing on Cloud Next.
It was a pretty awesome event.
It was really great.
I think there were
thousands of people.
Lots of cloud people
from Cloud Tokyo.
And I also learned
something very important.
I didn't realize this, but
their local GCP community
is called CF Pug.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's cute.
MARK MANDEL: So
a GCP user group.
And they have a logo with
a pug inside the hexagon,
and it's a pug.
It's awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: So that's a
group I need to be involved in.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
I have a sticker
on my laptop now.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, so overall it was a great
experience it sounds like.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It was fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I'm
glad you've made it back.
MARK MANDEL: How was Indaba?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I was going to say,
last week we were
sharing the episode we recorded
in Stellenbosch, Africa, which
was at Deep Learning
Indaba, and it was great.
And one thing I forgot
to mention last week
was that one of the
awards that was given out
for the best posters was
Google Cloud Platform credits.
We gave out $1,000
worth of credits
for 25 different posters.
So it was really
great, and I'm glad we
were able to do the podcast
and record from there.
We have a couple more podcasts
that we'll be sharing out
later next month.
MARK MANDEL: And
thank you to you,
Melanie, for taking care of the
podcast while I was in Japan.
I really appreciate it.
MELANIE WARRICK: It was fun.
For anybody who wants to know
the difference between a South
African accent and
an Australian accent,
you should listen to
last week's episode
and then all the other episodes.
We can compare.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds about right.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anyways,
because we had some help
from a few folks over there.
So, Mark, what's
going on this week?
MARK MANDEL: So this
week we're bringing back
a interview that we did while we
were at Next earlier this year.
So the Next in San
Francisco this time.
We had a great discussion with
the team from Wellio with Sivan
and Erik, talking
about all the data
science things they
do over at Wellio.
It was really, really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: It was.
It was a full picture.
That was the nice thing
was seeing applied machine
learning, but from
the start to the end,
from coming up with the
concept and the problem
and then actually
to the deployment.
It was really a
valuable interview.
So I'm glad we're finally
going to get a chance
to share that with everyone.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
A really great one.
And then we have a question
of the week this afternoon.
We're going to step away
from the GCP side of things
and move back maybe a
little to the Google Cloud.
So we did hear that
Inbox is going away,
which makes me very sad.
But we're going to
talk about what can we
do with the Gmail features
that are moved across
and talk a little bit about
that and what sort of things
you can use once Inbox is gone.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
How to move forward with
Gmail and as Inbox goes away.
We're going to have
a therapy session.
It's all good.
All right.
So, as always, we start off with
our cool things of the week.
We have a couple things that
are generally available now.
Data Studio and Data Prep-- so
Data Studio being this great BI
tool that we've been providing.
It's working with more than 500
data sources and more than 100
partner-built connectors.
And it's used by over
a million people.
It's a pretty
well-used tool that's
out there in terms of
business intelligence.
And Data Prep, of
course, allowing
you to prepare your
data-- when you're
doing any type of analysis
or machine learning with it,
there's a lot of work sometimes
you have to do to clean it up.
And the data prep tool
allows you to do that.
And now that it's generally
available, it's got a new look.
It allows for things
like team collaboration
and some additional features.
So yeah, those are nice.
MARK MANDEL: That is nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And speaking
of generally available,
we also have Cloud
Memorystore for Redis
going generally available.
So if you're looking for
a managed Redis system,
you can come to us
for that as well.
And we also expanded it
to several new regions.
So now Cloud Memorystore is
supported in Tokyo, Singapore,
and Netherlands, which are new,
as well as Oregon, Iowa, South
Carolina, Belgium, and Taiwan.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Another cool thing of the week--
I know earlier this
year, in May, we
were talking about the
Coursera courses that
came out for TensorFlow.
And these were the
machine learning
with TensorFlow and Google
Cloud Platform course that's
a five-course specialization.
And it's, like, now
in the top 10 data
science specializations on
Coursera that's out there.
Following on to that they went
with a more advanced machine
learning TensorFlow course that
has been released recently.
And this advanced course covers
topics like end-to-end machine
learning with TensorFlow
and Google Cloud Platform,
production machine
learning systems,
image understanding with
TensorFlow and Google Cloud,
sequence models for time
series and natural language
processing, and recommendation
systems with TensorFlow.
So this is something that will
help take you another step down
the path of expanding your
machine learning expertise.
And there's going to be a
webinar on October 9 at 9:00 AM
to learn more about the course.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Speaking of machine learning
as well, teammates of ours,
Sara Robinson and
Zack Akil, recently
released a blog post on
the Google Cloud blog
called "Simplifying ML
Predictions with Google Cloud
Functions."
This is a really great
hands-on blog post
that takes you
through all the code
that they use to
write Cloud Functions,
calling cloud ML from
the Cloud Function,
and going all the way through.
It's actually a
really great read.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, it is.
And it's great to get this
out from our teammates.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: And the
last thing we want to mention
is that Mark Moore gave us a
shout-out as one of the 50 best
cloud security podcasts in
an article that he wrote.
And he gave us a
nice little overview
in terms of some of the podcast
episodes in particular that he
found especially useful,
and one of those, of course,
being the Vint Cerf
episode, which I agree
was a very valuable episode that
you guys captured last year.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very much
for including us in your list.
It was much appreciated.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
All right, Mark, I think it's
time for us to go and talk
with Wellio.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think we did enough
cool things of the week.
Let's go talk with Wellio.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: So it's
day three here at Next,
and it's the final
interview, but super-excited.
We have two wonderful
people with us.
I'm going to probably
massacre your names,
but we'll try our very best.
Sivan Aldor-Noiman.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
VP of data science at Wellio.
And Erik Andrejko.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my god.
I'm doing really well.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Also CTO of Wellio.
Thank you so much for joining
us and taking time out of Next
to come hang out with us.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yes.
It's our pleasure.
ERIK ANDREJKO:
Thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
We want to hear all
about what you're
doing at Wellio, how you do it,
like, how all this stuff works,
basically.
But do you want to
tell us a little bit
about who both of you are
and what it is you do?
Sivan, you want to go first?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Sure.
So my name's Sivan, and it's
a nice Israeli name, Hebrew
name--
Hebrew month.
My background's in statistics.
So I have a master and a
PhD in the statistics world.
And I was kind of intrigued
in applying statistics
to temporal spatial
models, so that's
where I started my career.
And I worked for several years
in the agriculture technology
space alongside Erik, actually.
And after several years there
I transitioned to Wellio.
And in Wellio, we work on the
food technology space, which
is kind of in a similar space.
Right?
They're related to
each other, but one
tackles more the demand side
and the other the supply side.
So after several years in
the supply side of food,
I really wanted
to move to demand.
Because if you want
to change supply,
you really should
just change demand.
That's much easier.
So I joined Wellio, and I've
been developing models for
and recommendation
systems for food.
And I think we'll tell
you a little bit more
about Wellio in a minute.
But, yeah, I build
models for life.
I am a super-duper
happy statistician,
data scientist/machine learner
and all the words above that
describe the same position.
MARK MANDEL: And
you like chocolate.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: And
I love dark chocolate.
Correct.
ERIK ANDREJKO: And I'm Erik.
I'm CTO and
co-founder of Wellio.
My background is very similar
to Sivan's in some ways.
I am trained as a
computer scientist.
I did a PhD, actually,
in pure math.
I think of myself as a
disillusioned mathematician.
I got a little tired
of staring at the wall
and wanted to do something
a little more impactful.
So I came out to the
Bay Area, and I've
been working in machine
learning ever since.
And Wellio kind of grew
out of a personal problem
that I had that I think is
shared by many people, which
is to feed my family
at home healthy meals
and make good
decisions about food
in ways that make eating at
home the easiest and healthiest
choice.
And especially when making
decisions under duress,
like with a crying
kid and hungry,
that's exactly the moment when I
want machines to make decisions
for me because I know I
won't make a good one.
And I had all this
exposure to technology
that was helping make
nutrition decisions for plants,
but I had none of that
technology for my own family.
So I wanted to
create the experience
of having a personal chef
and nutritionist in the house
to help with meal
planning and grocery
shopping and those
sorts of things.
And I imagined a way in
which that could be embodied
in an intelligent machine.
And so that's kind of
how we got to here.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: When we
talk about Wellio we talk about,
how can we make a
personalized family
nutritionist available
to everyone in the world,
not just someone
that can afford it?
We both have families.
I have two kids.
So we've tackled the
problem of, like, how
do you feed everyone
in the family?
How do you personalize it?
I'm on a diet.
My husband likes
these kind of foods.
My kids don't eat
these types of foods.
So how do we really cook at
home so that everyone's happy,
everyone's healthy?
And also the other
side is, how do we
make people learn the
relationship between food
and their well-being?
Which is very hard;
it's very hard to know.
And you look at trends
of how people have
thought about diets over time.
It changes.
Right?
One decade, it's you need more
vitamin C. In the next decade,
it's vitamin D and like, oh,
eat more meat, eat less meat.
There's not a lot of consistent
science in this domain
and definitely very hard
to personalize that domain.
And that's sort of the problem
we're trying to tackle.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
how does Wellio work?
ERIK ANDREJKO: That's
a very good question.
So there's two things to Wellio.
There's the technology
platform, which is really
ultimately designed
to be an AI for food,
if you excuse the buzzword
for this type of audience.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
What does the user
experience look like?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
And so on top of the
user experience--
one user experience we are
testing in the market today
is-- it's essentially a
virtual culinary assistant.
So you say something
like, I would
like to eat shrimp tacos
tonight, and then it knows,
oh, you probably
want corn tortillas
because there's someone in
the house who's gluten-free.
You like these brands.
You need this
number of servings.
You'll probably
like this recipe,
but it needs to be modified a
little bit to make it spicy,
less spicy, reduce
the fat content,
increase the protein
content, something like that.
And the system goes
out, translates
that high-level request into
a specific grocery order.
It executes the
grocery order for you,
and then through
one of our partners
we deliver a bag of groceries
and customized recipes
to you the same day.
So it translates a high-level
intent into dinner tonight.
MELANIE WARRICK: And what
markets do you serve?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Right now
we're not publicly available,
although, you can sign
up for our beta list.
And we can currently serve
about 60% of the US market.
We're mostly limited
on availability
of delivery partner.
And we partner
with Amazon Fresh,
Instacart-- people like
that to actually do
the last mile on delivery.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
So in terms of data science,
how does data science
play a role into this?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: So from
minute zero, data and data
science played a
really big role.
So I think you can
imagine you can
build this company in two ways.
One is you can start
with very limited meals,
bring an expert in the
domain, like a chef,
and start creating very
tiny little recipes
and start promoting
those recipes.
And over time you would
increase your database
and make it bigger and learn
intent and so on and so on.
We did not go that path.
We didn't feel that's
a scalable path.
And really from
the get go we said,
we really want to understand
the culinary space and the food
space.
And in order to do that from,
like, as a data scientist,
what you first need
is a big data set.
And so we went out and got a
vast amount of data, recipe
data, for example, and blog data
on food, and articles on food,
and we generated a
gigantic database
with food-related information.
And then we could start
training models on top of it.
And when Erik says,
like, translating intent
to a shopping list
and doing all of that,
there is a lot of models
that come into play.
From taking this
unstructured data,
whether it's the intent or even
if you think about the data
that we've accumulated-- like,
if you look at a recipe data
from different varieties and you
really think about not a single
web site but many,
many web sites--
it's unstructured data.
So the first thing
you have to do
is apply some way
to structure it.
And we took a very
machine learning,
deep learning approaches, and
we structured it using models.
And once the data is
structured, then you
can start building
recommendation systems
on top of them that
would recommend
what recipe, how to
adapt the recipe,
personalize it to a
certain person or a family.
Even, like, how to make
it into a shopping list.
So now that you
have a recipe, how
do you personalize
the shopping list?
Maybe it's particular
stores that people like
or brands or particular
items that they prefer--
organic, for example,
or traditional.
So all these
personalizations on top
is another part where the
machine learning and data
science comes in.
MELANIE WARRICK: And where
does your data come from?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: The data
comes from propriety sources
and also from the web.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got it.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
So it's a combo.
MARK MANDEL: So
when you're doing--
and this is maybe my
naive understanding
of the machine learning
side of things--
but when you're doing
these deep model
analyses of, like, the
data that you have,
are you essentially categorizing
it so that people can use it
or, like, tagging it?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: For
us there's definitely
a level of structuring.
So when you think
of a recipe you
can think of ingredients
and preparation lines.
So one type of
structuring is to take,
for example, an ingredient
line and extracting certain
information from that alone--
like, for example, if it
says one cup of sugar,
you would need to know that
sugar is the actual food
entity that was in
that line, and the cup
is the unit of measure,
and one is the amount.
So one is structuring--
that kind of structuring.
And, yeah-- which is kind of
annotation, things like that.
And the other one is
deriving additional labels.
So, for example, cuisine
type, or the type of course,
or things like that.
So that's another type
of classification models
that we have to
develop and write.
Yeah.
ERIK ANDREJKO: I mean,
there's some other things
that we've done that are very
interesting that are more
on the latent semantics space.
So, for example, on top of
this parsing of recipes,
you now have a data
set where you have
co-occurrence of food terms.
So parmesan and tomatoes
co-occur quite frequently
for some reason, and
you can actually build,
essentially, something
just like word2vec.
You can build vector
representations
of these food terms.
And the vector representations
capture culinary use.
So if you look in the
vector space for things
that are very close
to parmesan, you
find all of the other
Italian cheeses--
Reggiano, et cetera, et cetera.
And so by kind of taking this
even semi-structured data
and then using some of
the techniques we all know
and love, you can get pretty
rich representations that you
can then use as good signals
or features for other machine
learning models that
maybe are more--
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
For example, ingredient
substitutions.
You can think about it that way.
Right?
You can think of
generative recipes,
all sorts of these kind of
applications on top of it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are you
doing generative recipes?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
Uh, I would not
say that we've conquered
generative recipes.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
you're exploring it.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
But we're exploring it.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Especially from ingredients--
I know for people who--
they may have certain types
of ingredients in their house,
and some of these
recipes can be very--
ERIK ANDREJKO: Exactly.
MELANIE WARRICK: Like,
a barrier to entry
sometimes, with some of the
ingredients they ask for.
It's nice when you can
see what's easy to swap.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
And I mean, there's also
very practical things.
Because oftentimes you go to the
grocery store and the grocery
stores themselves don't know
what inventory they have.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
ERIK ANDREJKO: And they may
have run out of the thing
that you intended
to buy, so you need
to make a decision in the
moment about what to do.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
MARK MANDEL: And so once you've
got the data set for the food,
essentially, and the
ingredients and the recipes,
I'm guessing there's
another side, which
is like the consumer's
wants and needs.
And how do you mush the
two things together?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
That's the personalization step.
Right?
So there's kind of two types
that Erik mentioned when he
sort of described the journey.
One is more about, like,
the type of things I like,
my taste.
I like these types
of recipes, or I'm
following a certain diet.
Right?
Paleo or keto--
MELANIE WARRICK: Diabetes.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: There's
the health conditions
that could sort of also
dictate certain things.
And then there's-- like, that's
more on the food domain when
you ask people.
And then there's more on the
shopping domain, which is like,
what kind of stores
do I like to shop in?
And what kind of grocery
items do I usually buy?
What my budget is.
I have other kind of
constraints that may come in.
Or what do I have in my pantry?
And how do I bring it?
Or, I dislike these types--
like, I hate pickles.
So if you bring me a
recipe with pickles,
you're going to have to
recommend some alternatives
to those pickles.
So there's all this information.
Some of it we can ask directly.
A lot of other companies do,
like, very, very directly.
Right?
Like a diet-- are you
on a specific diet?
Dislikes and likes,
things like that.
And others, I think, we've
taken a more different approach.
Like, for example,
taste for me-- people
can describe what
they like, but it's
much easier and maybe much
more informative to not ask it
directly but indirectly
by asking them
to choose a set of
recipes from a list,
or to learn it over time
because they're selecting
more and more recipes so you can
over time adapt to their taste
better, or explore their taste
varieties that they like.
As opposed to asking if
you prefer savory or sweet
or things like that.
People may say it, but
they may not always
exactly want that one thing.
They may want to venture out.
So some things we collect
very directly by asking,
and others kind of indirectly
through the interaction
with the app itself.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That makes sense.
I'm just thinking, like,
if you asked me directly
what movies I watch,
I would probably
tell you arthouse
because I am cultured.
But if I'm at
home, I am probably
watching "Terminator 2."
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Or "Glow."
Anyways-- no plugging there.
So this is great.
What are some of the GCP
products that you're using?
ERIK ANDREJKO: I
think it may be easier
to say which GCP
products we're not using.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's a new one.
Let's try that.
ERIK ANDREJKO: What
are we not using?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: BigTable.
ERIK ANDREJKO: We're
not using Bigtable.
That's about it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
So you're using everything else?
ERIK ANDREJKO: We're
not using Bigtable.
We're not using Spanner.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Do you use TPUs?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Why don't we
start on the journey where
you started, which is, like,
the data side of things.
So where does that data go
and how do you process it?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yes.
Actually, so the first
thing we did build
was the crawling system.
Because I'm a data scientist.
I've worked with
many data scientists.
I've never met a data scientist
who didn't want more data.
So I figured we'd
better have data
if we're going to be successful.
So we built a crawling system
that's built in Python.
The actual operations
of it is heavily
influenced by the availability
of things like GKE.
That runs on GKE
autoscales on GKE.
And all of the data coming out
of that is dumped on to GCS.
And then all of
the post-processing
happens via Pub/Sub.
So there's various stages.
It goes through kind of a stage
pipeline that's all coordinated
by my Pub/Sub, and there
are various GKE clusters
that read the messages--
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: It's also
stored on BigQuery even when
it's unstructured.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
There's some-- a whole bunch
of side channels that--
out of this pipeline
we collect data
at various levels
of normalization.
That is available
on GCS in some rawer
form, which we can then access,
and we do access via Dataproc.
But primarily it
ends up in BigQuery.
And then most of the
machine learning,
either kind of in an ad hoc
or in a more formal repeated
training.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are you using
Dataproc with more, like,
a Hadoop or with a Spark or--
ERIK ANDREJKO: With Spark.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got it.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
Actually, we're increasingly
kind of automating
a lot of our model training
evaluation and deployment
pipelines on Composer.
MARK MANDEL: Tell
us about Composer,
because I think that's very new.
In fact, I have no
idea what it is.
ERIK ANDREJKO:
Composer is essentially
an orchestration layer.
It's hosted Airflow.
Airflow seems to have
been increasingly
widely-used in the industry
for doing machine learning
pipelines where I have-- step A,
I transform some data; step B,
I maybe need to train a model.
Next step is maybe I do a
model evaluation, and then
my model selection, and
then I need to deploy it.
So if you want to
run model training
on some schedule
like that, we've
been doing that
recently in Composer,
and that's worked very well.
There's a lot of nice hooks
for some of the other GCP
offerings, for instance
Cloud ML Engine.
We use a lot of Cloud ML
Engine with Keras, actually,
increasingly.
And we launch our training
jobs directly from Composer
as we get new data coming in--
new label data or
new unstructured data
depending on the pipeline.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
And we do have
several models that
really are kind of continuous
integration development
and deployment in the sense
that we've developed them.
We train them.
We get all of that
from Composer.
And then there is
a human in the loop
that once the output
of the model is shown,
we have an internal tool that
would show the model output.
Internally in our
team we have experts--
domain experts, chefs, and
people in the culinary space--
that would review the labels
that the model produced.
For example, like,
we talked about it
could say the type of
cuisine or things like that.
And they would correct, and we
would collect that corrected
data, and then we
can sort of train
again the model with more data
so that over time the model
improves.
And we can monitor
that improvement.
So we definitely have
kind of those mechanisms.
MARK MANDEL: That's
actually really interesting.
So you're not just ML.
And, as you said
before, you were like,
we're not just
going to do human.
It's kind of the
combination of both,
or a little bit of tweaking?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: A lot of
all companies do that, too.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
I think we-- even
with our experience
from our previous company,
it's very clear to us
that machine learnings
and models-- and, I guess,
that's also my background.
It's like, I cannot in good
conscience have a model that I
believe will always be right.
There's always going
to be cases where
a model's going to be wrong.
And, as Erik said,
as a data scientist
I'm always going
to want more data.
So having experts in
the room talking to you,
helping you understand the
data-- and I would admit,
I cooked before coming to
Wellio, but I am not a chef,
and I am not an
expert in this domain.
So having that domain
expert sit next to me
and asking lots of
questions about the data
so that I understand how to
properly utilize it really
helps.
And so, yeah, we've
devised the mechanism
so that we can kind of get the
most from this domain expert
and scale in some sense.
MELANIE WARRICK:
When the data is
being flowed through your
ETL and through the data
and doing the training,
is it batched?
Is it streaming?
Is it a mix?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: It's a mix.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
It's a mix.
It's primarily batch
today, especially
in the training side.
I think going forward it'll
be more online and streaming.
We do do streaming in
another way in which we do
human-in-the-loop.
And that is to have
human-in-the-loop kind
of operationally.
So we have a system
where a model
will be selecting a grocery
list, say, for an individual.
And then the model will also
output some confidence scores
with respect to the
rankings it's made
in terms of the grocery items.
And then if that falls
below some threshold,
we actually will shunt some
that work to a human expert,
and the human expert
can review and override
some of the
model-based decisions.
And that's entirely
streaming-- that process.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
I would say we have
sufficient data that we
don't get a lot from
training online,
like, from every observation.
We probably do need
enough quantity
to sort of move
the needle again.
Because the needle is already
kind of quite high, so to move
it again takes a while.
And so I think the system
that Erik describes helps
us deal with outliers
and things that
don't work all the way like
it should-- because they're
outlier, and they will take
time for the machine learning
to sort of get all those
kind of edge cases.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I'm
also curious in terms
of your setup, are you using--
from the more data-engineering
side of things--
Stackdriver and other
performance tools, too?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Oh, yeah.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: To make
sure the system's functioning
the way you want it to?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
When Erik said, you know,
ask us what we're not using,
it's actually right.
It's probably true.
You know, there's a
presentation with all the Google
icons in them.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: But I
think we can highlight many,
many of the icons that we use.
We're really-- not just
the data science but also
the engineering side-- very
adventurous and up-to-date
with the current
technology that Google
is offering so that we can
adapt quickly and move fast.
And I think we've been
really, really good at, like--
I know a lot of
beta-- like Composer
and other things
that are in pure beta
that we are really adapting
already into our stack.
I got excited in this
conference to hear more
about Cloud Function
and bringing Python
into the mix of it.
So I'm eager to test that
in our infrastructure.
We don't have that yet.
But definitely other
components from Google
has made it very easy,
as a data scientist,
to sort of explore data,
push models into production.
It's been a really nice
platform to work with.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you
mentioned some of the models
that you're working
with are recommend--
well, a lot of
these end up being
some form of recommendation
or classification anyways.
And it sounds like
you're using ML Engine,
or you said you were
using ML Engine.
So you're using
neural nets then?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Some are--
yeah.
Some are, like, deep
learning nets and some are--
I like to call them shallow
models now that everyone really
loves the buzzwords
of deep models.
So, yeah, we use a combination
of shallow and deep model
depending on the application.
But a lot of it--
we talked about-- we have
these semantic representation
of certain things, and
then we might train a more
shallow model on top of it.
Right?
So Transfer Learn
and things like that.
So we have a combo
of these approaches.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are
you using other things,
like random forests
and linear regressions,
based on the types
of other problems
that you're working on?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Most
companies would be.
Yeah.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
It's a combination.
I really am not--
I'm trained as a statistician,
so I'd rather be--
and I'm practical.
So I'm like, OK, what
is the right approach
for this problem?
And I don't believe the deep
learning is the solution to all
of the problems in the world.
I believe that you need
to understand the data.
You need to understand what
you're trying to solve.
Sometimes simple
approaches can get you
what you need in order to
solve the business problem.
ERIK ANDREJKO: It tends to be a
very layered approach in that--
like, the models that are
consuming, essentially,
unstructured data--
that could be raw text,
that could be
images, for example--
tend to be deep neural networks.
And then they output some
vector representation
or some additional
auxiliary data
or labeling that then can be
fed into an application-specific
model.
And sometimes a model is
a deep neural network,
but very often it's not.
MARK MANDEL: How are you
serving these models?
Like, how do you end up
using them at the end?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
We serve them-- well, we have
a microservices architecture.
And so everything,
for the most part,
ends up in GKE in
some form or another.
We are starting to
increasingly use
Cloud ML Engine as a deployment
platform when we can.
I'm excited to
try that with more
frameworks than TensorFlow.
We've done it with TensorFlow.
I'm excited to try that
outside of TensorFlow.
Because we like to
think about the models
we produce as
essentially appliances,
and then the engineering
organization can just
use them as any other service.
It's just another
API that you call.
We're a very small team.
We have no platform
engineering team.
GCP is our platform
So we either have none
or we have a giant one,
depending on how you look at it.
And we have no operations team.
Everyone just kind
of owns operations,
and that includes all
the data scientists.
So all the machine learning
operations, online models
monitoring, performance
monitoring of Stackdriver,
for example, that's
all done by--
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: By us.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
By all of us.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: By
our data scientists.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So that's really interesting.
And you're using a lot of
very different pieces of GCP,
but you're all learning
it with a small team.
Are you facing any
challenges about, basically,
using so many things?
Or are you finding it nice?
Or how's that experience like?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Well, I mean,
some things are kind of new,
I think, to the data science
industry, in some ways.
I mean, most times when we
talk to other data scientists,
they're not super familiar
with Kubernetes, for example.
So that's just new.
But I think what
we found is very
nice is that the
abstraction layers of GCP
seem to be well-considered in
that you don't have to relearn
API primitives or command line
interfaces over and over again
to use different
parts of the system.
There is a fair
amount of consistency.
And so once our
engineers or data
scientists kind of grok the
underlying conceptual space,
using it tends to
be pretty easy.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: And there's
some learning that you need
to do in order to ramp up on
the different technologies,
but I feel like--
like, I'd never worked on
the Google Cloud Platform
before joining Wellio.
And, yeah, it took a while,
but not as much as it took me
other platforms.
So that's a good thing.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: That's
the sound bite.
Thank you.
We're done.
[LAUGHING]
MELANIE WARRICK: Two different
questions I want to ask.
Earlier, before,
you were saying you
want to try to
make it accessible
outside of TensorFlow.
Is there a reason why you
want to be able to explore
beyond TensorFlow?
And is there specific
software that you'd
be more interested in?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Well, as Sivan
was saying, our, quote unquote,
"shallow models"--
I love this
branding, by the way.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: I say it
constantly, shallow and deep.
I find it very funny
that people call it deep,
and now there's no alternative.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
Once you go deep
it's hard to say
I'm not doing anything deep.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
It's shallow.
[LAUGHING]
ERIK ANDREJKO: So for our
non-deep neural network models,
they're primarily scikit-learn.
And so to be able to deploy
those as individual RESTful
interfaces would be very useful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Scikit-learn is very popular.
Yes.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yes.
Scikit-learn is very popular.
I think we could
do both of those.
And then that allows us
also to do model-versioning
so that we can do A/B testing
or canary deployments.
That's something we
want to do more of.
And it provides
us safety nets so
that we can more quickly deploy
new models for production.
And we don't have to
be so careful in terms
of the testing, but we
can deploy and monitor,
and then we have the safety
to roll if we need to.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And you were saying
how it took a little bit
of time to get up to speed.
Any tips or tricks
or advice for those
who are exploring GCP
for the first time,
trying to build out their own
solutions for their company?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: So I was
in a bigger company before.
So in a bigger company
data scientist-- at least
in my experience-- they really
have a very specific role.
They don't really do
the data engineering.
That's done by someone else.
They're very, very
data science, meaning
we build-- you look at the
data, you build a model,
and you push it to someone else.
And I think my biggest
problem was like,
oh, I now need to learn all
the data engineering side
because no one's
going to do it for me.
Oh, I need to learn DevOps
because there's no DevOps team.
Oh, I need to do
all these things.
So it was more
tackling those things.
I think from a data
science perspective--
like, if my role in this
company was just look at data,
develop models, and
push it, this platform
makes it extremely
easy to do those tasks.
Really.
Like, accessing the data
in different formats
from different
locations has become
extremely easy and simple.
Spinning up your
own notebooks to be
able to explore the data from
different places is very easy.
Deploying the model now
becomes extremely easy
too with Cloud ML.
So it's a platform that's
designed, in some sense,
for a data scientist
to play around with.
I think it becomes more
challenging when you're like,
yeah, you're also the
engineer and the DevOps
so you need to learn
about Kubernetes
and you need-- oh
yeah, you do need
to understand all these things.
Then it becomes a little
bit more complicated.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
also mentioned earlier
that you are using TPUs.
How are you using TPUs?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
For training purposes.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
Well, one thing that's
very important for us
is to think about
our biggest costs.
And our biggest cost
is opportunity cost
in that we don't have an
infinite number of software
engineers.
So if a software engineer is
doing x, they're not doing y.
And that means-- especially
for people building models--
that the faster they can
get to the next iteration
result, the better.
So that is reducing
training time.
And we use accelerators
and TPUs and GPUs
for reducing time to answer.
And the other thing that
we increasingly use,
which has been very
beneficial for us,
is the hyperparameter
optimization.
So it used to be that we would
have these long discussions.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: That's true.
ERIK ANDREJKO: People thought
that their job as a data
scientist was to know and
have intuition about what
type of parameters to choose.
And now I tell them, don't
really worry about that.
We'll just run a big experiment.
And I'd rather
have the experiment
running than spend
another couple of days
thinking about which
parameters should be used.
MARK MANDEL: What's the issue
there for people who aren't
familiar with that space?
ERIK ANDREJKO: When you build--
say you take a deep
neural network.
You have to decide how many
layers you should have,
how big each layer
should be, which
units you have in each layer.
You could choose
from different units.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Activation functions.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
I mean, there's just
a smorgasbord of--
MELANIE WARRICK: The way
I like to explain it--
and I'm just going to jump
in with this-- is it's almost
like you have one of
those very complex radios
that you can tune all
the things for the radio
to make the sound sound
like a certain quality.
But you've got to be an
expert on how to tune it,
and that can be a challenge.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
That can be a challenge.
And the alternative
to being an expert
is, let the machine
worry about that.
Because then you can
go on to doing things
that I think are higher value,
which is what problems should
we be solving, what work
should we prioritize,
which new model should we build?
And let the platform
do the fine-tuning.
I think we've seen the
same thing, by the way,
with feature engineering.
And I've had discussions
with data scientists--
even Googlers, data
scientists-- who
told me that they think their
job is getting automated away.
Because their job used to
be to look at some raw data,
and then they could
figure out how
to encode the raw
data in these features
that would work well in
a machine-learned model.
And now, with deep
neural networks,
the network does
most of the encoding.
And it does a better job
of encoding the raw input
than most data scientists do,
so that the data scientist's
job is no longer to
be a feature engineer.
And I think the next phase is
the data scientist's job is not
going to be to be
choosing hyperparameters,
and then it's probably
going to be not to be
choosing model architectures.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, and that starts
to touch into Auto ML too,
which-- have you explored
that yet?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: A little.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yes.
That's on the list of
things we have used.
Yeah.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
[LAUGHS] We've done-- like,
we tried once or twice.
There might be good
use cases for it,
and I agree that some
automation is good.
But maybe my own
internal thing is,
like, I want to see the model.
I need to see the actual
architecture and what it does.
And I believe in the
technology of deep learning.
I understand it mathematically.
I understand where it's going.
But I also believe that the
value of a data scientist
is in interpreting some
of these things sometimes,
and the more deep learning
is applied the less
people have an understanding--
even the people who actually
developed these models--
have a less understanding of
what's going on internally,
what are the actual
features it's creating,
how to explain it to anyone.
The causal things
that people like
to interpret with causality
becomes really hard.
So I think with Auto ML it's
even more obscure than normal.
I see a lot of benefit
for certain places,
especially if you
want to accelerate
certain things that are
very common tasks in machine
learning.
Then you should use it, because
there's-- you don't need
to hire today, like, a whole
suite of data scientists just
to build a model.
That's already kind of
implemented for you.
And it takes away that
magic of feature selection
and all of these things.
So I think it's very useful
for those kind of use cases.
If you have a data
scientist and they
know what they're doing,
letting them play around
with TensorFlow and building
models that you can better
grasp when they fail
and when they're good,
it's good for the organization.
So this is why, I guess, Erik
and I are a good pairing.
He pushes in that direction, and
I push in the other direction.
So on average it's fine.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, and one
other thing on the TPU side--
do you combine those with GPUs
and CPUs in the calculations,
in the computations
that you're doing?
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
That's one thing
that I would say
is still a challenge
for us, which
is when you have a
particular model training
job, having to decide the
compute infrastructure.
Because sometimes
it's actually--
especially in dollar
terms, that requires a lot
of trial and error on our part.
I'd love to be able
to just set a budget.
I would like to train this
model for this many dollars
and be able to trade off time
to conversions and dollars.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, that sounds
like a good product to build.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
A forecaster.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yeah.
Because what we do now
is we'll run a job,
and we'll use just
distributed CPU training,
and then we'll compare
that with a single GPU,
and then you can choose
your flavors of GPUs or TPU.
And then we have to
decide, for that class
of models, which one
we think we should
use as the standard in
our Composer workflow,
which is in the
automated training.
That's a very operational,
optimization decision
that most, I think-- most
data scientists probably
don't want to do.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: But I've
seen talks in this conference--
talk a lot about the
engineering costs,
and they less focus
about these topics of,
like, oh, how much does it
take to train your model.
It's more about,
if you have an app,
where should you deploy it,
and how much it will cost you,
or, like, operationally
what's going on.
And I think this is kind
of an area that hasn't yet
been fully explored maybe.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
and on that point,
what have you seen at Next
that you've been excited about
or that you're interested
in looking into further?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: We
actually made a list.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Yes.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
Just before coming here,
without knowing that this
was going to be a question--
and there were
quite a few things.
So I got really excited
about Cloud Functions.
I can see immediate
benefits, and I
like that there's a
Python beta version.
So I'm like, OK.
We might want to try that.
We might want to
venture into that.
There's some Google
Vision that we looked at
that we were like, oh, we might
be able to capitalize on it.
There's some really cool new
things that were shown there.
I actually went to an amazing
talk that maybe is not new,
but just explained
it in a better way.
It was like a DevOps
advocater, but she was one
of the keynote speakers today.
MARK MANDEL: Was it Aja?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Aja.
MARK MANDEL: Aja's great.
She's on our team.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: She
gave a talk yesterday
with kind of tips for DevOps,
for people who are not DevOps.
And I would-- like, it's going
to be on YouTube I heard,
so I would highly
recommend that one.
MARK MANDEL: We'll find it.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: It was
a very, very good talk.
And so I'm excited to
take some of the learnings
she suggested there.
I was telling Erik there was
a talk about Traffic Director.
We Googled it and
couldn't find it,
so there's an alpha
version of something
called Traffic Director.
Istio and it works
well with Envoy.
And so all of these
things-- we're like,
oh, those are interesting things
we should start thinking about.
And then the last one
was the Firestore stuff
that were mentioned throughout
lots of things here in Next.
We were talking about Firestore.
So I thought there were
some nifty ideas on how
you kind of immediately go
from Firestore into BigQuery
and other kind of storages
so that the data can
get shown more quickly
to the data scientist
and to the models.
So I'm kind of excited
about that, too.
So lots of things.
MARK MANDEL:
Anything on your end,
or is that the entire list?
It was a great list.
ERIK ANDREJKO: It's
pretty similar.
I mean, I think we're
increasingly, as a business,
providing our
platform to partners.
And that means giving
them access to APIs,
and that creates kind of
additional operational needs.
So I'm really
excited about Istio.
In terms of talks and kind of
ways to use Kubernetes well,
the developer keynote--
Kelsey Hightower's talk
was pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: No surprise there.
ERIK ANDREJKO: I actually had
the chance to, a few weeks ago,
serendipitously pair
program with them
at the end of dinner
for 15 minutes.
And I can say that the talk
is exactly like the pair
programming experience.
So I'm excited to
be able to use more
of the operational
elements, things like Istio
and Spinnaker, kind of really
extend GKE as an operations
platform and be able to do
less operations, especially
as we do B2B integrations.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, before we wrap up today,
is there anything we've missed
or anything you
want to make sure
that our listeners know about?
Are you hiring?
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: I
only eat dark chocolate
above a certain percent,
otherwise the experience
is very bad.
And don't eat 100% because
that's also very bad.
I'm serious.
[LAUGHTER]
That's one very important tip.
We are hiring.
We're looking for back-end
engineering slash data
engineering to join my team.
So definitely that.
We also have--
ERIK ANDREJKO: We're hiring
in all kinds of roles.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Senior
application developer.
So definitely people
on that spectrum.
And I think if you're generally
interested in the food tech
space, it would be great
to get in touch with us.
I'm going to assume the email is
going to be somewhere visible.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN:
And so we'd be
always happy to
talk to people who
are passionate about this
space and have opinions.
Even if they're not
technology kind of people,
that's totally fine too.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, thank you
both for joining.
ERIK ANDREJKO: Thank you.
SIVAN ALDOR-NOIMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
So thanks again
to Sivan and Erik
for joining us on the podcast.
This was a great episode.
So glad that you had the time
to sit down with us at Next
and really share your knowledge
with how Wellio was built.
It was really awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
And I think that wraps it up
for our next interviews finally.
So thank you for being our
last, but definitely not
the least episode to be
able to share with everyone.
OK.
Mark, let's talk about Inbox.
Inbox is going to be going
away in the next six months,
is my understanding.
And so there's
been a lot of work
to make sure some
of the features
and functionality that inbox has
has been moved over to Gmail.
So what does that look like?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So that's a good question.
So first, Melanie,
are you an Inbox user?
MELANIE WARRICK: I have been.
MARK MANDEL: I am
definitely an Inbox user.
How do you feel?
[SAD MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: I-- um--
I'm OK.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're OK.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: I'm OK.
Most of everything's
been moved across.
The only feature that I would
like to see move across--
if anyone's listening--
I would love
to see Bundles move across.
If that happens, then I'm fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: They
do say that there's
some more additional
features they're
working on bringing over.
But I agree that in Inbox the
Snooze feature was my favorite.
And so when that
came into Gmail it
made it easier for me to
start adopting Gmail again.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So definitely, yeah.
Inbox is my life.
Inbox is my to-do list.
So there is-- yes.
March 2019 Inbox
is being shut down.
It was a wonderful
experiment, and so they're
moving a lot of the features
over, which is really good.
And a lot of features have
been moved over as well.
There is a transition guide
that has been written,
and so if you're looking
for snoozing of emails--
yep.
We can do that,
which is really good.
Because, yeah.
Snoozing is the best.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
can work offline.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You can do stuff offline,
which is awesome too.
Though I do
particularly appreciate
coming back to Gmail,
the new smart replies--
I really like that.
MELANIE WARRICK: So, yes.
We've got a transition
guide that we're
going to link for everyone
to see what types of features
have been brought over
to Gmail so you can have
an understanding of
how that will look
and how that will work.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And pretty much everything
has been moved over.
Right?
Like reminders-- if you
use those, which I do--
moving over to Google
Tasks is pretty seamless.
So you just need to
move that stuff across,
which is pretty good.
Like, Snooze is still there.
You can replicate Bundles
with using tags and filters.
So--
[SAD MUSIC PLAYING]
It's not-- it's not
the end of the world.
It's not the end of the world.
I'm.
OK.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is
not the end of the world.
And we highly
recommend, everyone,
that if you are using Inbox to
start taking a look at Gmail
again and see how
that is transformed.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You might actually
not recognize it,
because it did go through a big
redesign a little while ago.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And there's a
lot of really cool features
in there.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
where are you going to be?
What are you up to?
MARK MANDEL: You and I are
going to be in Strange Loop in--
MELANIE WARRICK: We are.
MARK MANDEL: Basically on
the day this comes out.
I think I'm flying in
later than you are.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
I know.
You're a little
bummed because you're
missing out on the museum
party that they do every year.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Apparently people want to meet
me and talk to me about stuff.
So, yes.
I will be late.
I am a little sad.
[GAME OVER TONE]
MELANIE WARRICK: But why
are you going to be late?
MARK MANDEL: Basically,
internal games meetings
stuff is basically the reason.
I'm chairing our
Internal Game Summit.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's good.
It's going to be awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is
going to be awesome.
And Strange Loop will
be really wonderful too.
And we're planning on
recording a podcast there
that we will share soon.
So you'll hear more
about that later.
And Mark, anywhere else you're
going to be in the next month?
MARK MANDEL: I don't think so.
I think October is going
to be relatively quiet.
There is a chance that
I will be at Unite LA.
That's probably where I will be.
I have no idea what I'm doing
there or what I'm doing,
but it seems likely that
I'll probably be at Unite LA.
Are you going anywhere?
MELANIE WARRICK: I am.
I'm going to be in
Portland, Maine the week
after Strange Loop.
I'm going to be
speaking at Oktoberfest.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Should be fun.
All right, Mark.
I think that's it
for us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: I think so, too.
So Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]